a really important thing now that you
know the product rule and the quotient
rule and the chain rule as you grow more
and more rules it's like cool I can do
more stuff but it becomes just as
important to be able to choose when is
the which tool is most appropriate in
which situation raise your hand if you
use the question rule for this question
heads up okay thank you hands down I
gave the question to you in a form that
makes it easy to use the question rule
it's a question there is though another
rule you could have used I'm not saying
whether it's easier or not but look at
it again carefully x over e to the X do
you agree I could have written this as X
e to the minus X you see what I've done
there I've used index laws to say all
that
e to the X on the bottom I can as I got
taught when I was like in year 8 I can
cross the line change the sign right so
it becomes a negative index that's what
means it's on the bottom
okay now this guy you don't need the
quotient rule 4 you can use the product
rule and generally I will do everything
I possibly can to avoid the question
rule cause it's gross I mean it works
but it's long it's error-prone so if you
can avoid it do it and often there are
other situations where so just look at
it and I mean it's a he's my first
answer right in fact that's one of the
big things you know when you do a test
you're like I ran out of time if you had
that feeling before like I had three
questions the N I couldn't do it's often
not because you were slow it's because
perhaps you just chose a method that
took longer some methods are longer than
others ok all right so can I please
actually haven't already to make this
heading why are we looking at all of
these derivatives of n exponential
functions because we want to use that as
a stepping stone to differentiating the
logarithmic function what's the
relationship between the exponential
function y equals e to the X for example
and the logarithmic function what's the
relationship said again sir
it's a little bit like the relationship
between addition and subtraction or the
relationship between squaring and taking
a square root and we call these inverses
right so you're looking at the same
reality but from two different
perspectives okay so what we're going to
do is have a look at how to
differentiate the logarithmic function
we're going to kind of do it twice the
first time I'm just going to give you
the bird's eye view and then honestly
that's the part that the Advanced Course
requires you to look at that's all you
need and then you can just start using
it that's what we're going to cover
first and then if you want you can just
have a go the exercise and get
comfortable using it however and then
gonna hit pause as some of you guys
going with the exercise and I'm going to
offer to those of you who want it I'm
gonna offer to those of you who want a
an explanation for why all of this
actually is true when you come out of
this you might feel like yeah but all
right there was a bit of hand wavy like
is that really true it looks true but is
it really true um this is not a proof
okay I will give you the proof but it's
not within the scope of the course so
that's just for those of you who really
want to know who like me I driven sort
of crazy just to accept things because
someone tells you so you actually know
enough to prove it for yourself and I
will give you that explanation so let's
start from the top we're going to do
this just like with signing course we're
going to start thinking about it
visually through the graph okay so let's
consider the graph of y equals the
natural log of X we're only interested
in this case just like over here where
you've got the log that has a base of
what what all the bases here
E thank you so Ln X of course is our
abbreviation for log base a of X you can
write either of them I am just lazy so
I'm gonna write this short or what now I
don't need this to be a beautiful graph
I just want the rough sense can I ask
you guys use your finger I just hold up
in the air can you show me what the
shape of this graph roughly looks like
can you just draw it in the air from
your face how would you do it I'm just
looking for some motion in your fingers
okay yeah okay I'm seeing a variety of
shape okay this is actually all right
they know I don't know what on earth
you're doing but let me help you and I'd
love you to have this drawn as well
underneath where you've written it so
draw yourself a set of back
the log curve looks like this it's very
nice easy graph to sketch you just have
like we there one one little arc there
okay and this is the rough shape of it
and there are a few important features
that we should put onto this right for
starters there's an intercept an
x-intercept does anyone know what the
x-intercept is what value is it mmm
honey it's one very good okay remember I
told you that logs and Exponential's
they're two things looked at from
opposite point of view just like the
exponential curves they have a
y-intercept of 1 the log curve has an x
intercept of 1 and I say that again
exponential curve y-intercept of 1 log
curve x intercept of 1 ok that's good
there's also another thing missing over
here what's missing over here that I
should draw on mmm this is not a
periodic function it's not a trig
function it just sort of does that
doesn't repeat what else am I missing
I'm missing an asymptote right this
curve it approaches the y-axis but it
never gets there okay so we should all
go ahead and we should draw this
vertical asymptote in what's its
equation or close it is something equals
zero but it's on the y axis it's x
equals y ok I'm pretty happy with that
we could put up more information but all
that we need is already on here now on
the basis of just that's very very
simple picture there's at least three
things at least three things that we can
see about the derivative of this graph
the derivative tells us about the
gradient right so what I want you to
look at is this graph here and ok he's
out who's that first thing so the log
curve is increasing which means that the
derivative is very good the derivative
is positive so I might say if y equals
log X I'm gonna say dy on DX it's going
to be greater than zero it's positive
and it always is positive it never like
turns around
it never stops it is always going to be
going up okay that's really good what
else can you tell me about the
derivative is there anything else you
can tell me
Scot numbers in it but then again all
derivatives have numbers in it can you
tell me something specific to this
derivative Shawn did you ever thought
okay so I've got the fact that it's
positive that's good and I guess we'd
get that from you know putting these on
plus signs it's going up going up going
up increasing as Sree said is the exact
weight let me ask you how much is it
increasing values they're always
increasing at the same amount hmm now we
don't wouldn't have a [ __ ] amount of
detail on here right okay so so it's
curved right it's curved it is going up
but I noticed that like if for example
you undo this to your page right if I
cover up most of the graph and just show
this little bar part over here right so
if I cover up this part and you can only
see this part do you agree that this
section is quite steep at the beginning
but then as you go further and further
to the right it's if you look at that
part for example that's not a steep is
it it's much shallower it's not a
stationary point that would mean it
stops but in fact if I kept drawing this
it would keep on going up and up and up
but just really really slow okay now
what that means is the derivative right
it decreases it gets smaller and it does
that forever and ever and ever it never
like goes faster again you know the X
cubed graph is sort of good picks up
this never picks up right so it's going
to decrease forever it's gonna get
smaller and smaller and smaller it's
going to get closer and closer to zero
it's never gonna pass zero though
because as you told me here it's grain
zero right very good
okay one last question for you and it's
kind of a weird thing so I'm gonna
highlight it for you because it's ask
you a question about where the
derivative doesn't appear can you tell
me about this part of the graph we
didn't I didn't even draw that part of a
Cartesian plane what's going on over
here for y equals log X what why isn't
why is it y equals log X over here
so do you mind the ex tells us about
gradient that's about how steep or
shallow dough is but the graph doesn't
even exist anything what's goin on
Shambo do we have a name for this right
when a function has a boundary it like
stops somewhere it exists only in a
particular place that's with D what's
that call domain right so the domain of
log X what is the domain of log X what's
the domain where can log X exist X is
greater than zero right you can you get
two x equals zero no you can't because
of the asymptote right so because this
graph only exists for X is greater than
zero the derivative also only exists for
x squared does that make sense okay so
it only exists before X is greater than
zero okay on the right hand side of the
graph is a color cool where you can say
that all right now I want you to think
is there a graph that you know about
that it always stays positive it gets
smaller and smaller and smaller forever
and I only wanted to exist on on one
part of a graph what would that look
like hmm now we can start to pieces
together let me show you on here I'm
gonna use my other color okay it's
positive over here and it's very
positive so I'm gonna say the the
gradient gonna be somewhere up here it's
gonna be high and positive because very
steep and then it sort of slows down do
you agree with that like it's it's time
to get slower and shallower and it's
gonna keep on slowing down it's gonna
keep on slowing down the further I go
the more it slows down do you agree it
never gets to actual zero but what what
shape do you get if you join those dots
do you Rick
do you recognize this shape it starts
with um starts with an H what is this
guy this is the hyperbola right this
this graph I've just drawn is 1 over X
okay so this is our conclusion from just
looking at it visually right our visual
intuition
it tells us that the derivative of log X
it is what do we say what's the
hyperbola what's its equation 1 over X
but but but be careful 1 over X right
you don't have to draw this one over X
where does that exist what is the domain
of 1 over X well it exists over here
that's the part I've drawn but is that
the only place it exists no it also
exists on the other side right does this
ring a bell does that look like yeah
I've seen this before
okay so we actually don't want all of
the graph we only want the part that's
positive okay so this is the result that
we need to be using put a big box around
that we haven't proved it but we can
still use it if you get given a log
function you now know what it's
derivative is it's 1 over X but it's
this this part of 1 over x ok